Hi! I am Tom Cech. And I've been asked to talk about my favorite experiment.
Why did I pick  this particular experiment?
Well... It was one that I did with my own hands,
and there is something special about discovering something through your own work in the lab.
That is, as much as I enjoy working with students and postdoctoral fellows
and exalt over their discoveries,
something special about being able to make a discovery by yourself.
This came when we were looking at initially the transcription
of a large ribosomal RNA precursor
in a single cell pond animal, Tetrahymena thermophila.
The gene that we were looking at made an RNA that
was interrupted by a stretch of non-coding sequence,
called an intron. And at this time, RNA splicing had been discovered a few years earlier,
but people knew very little about the mechanism by which an intron containing RNA
would be spliced to rejoin these two flanking sequences called exons
and release that intron RNA.  Now we had found in our studies of transcription of this gene
that the RNA splicing was taking place outside of the cell, in vitro, with our purified extracted RNA.
So this seemed to be an opportunity for us to investigate the mechanism of RNA splicing.
Initially this splicing reaction was taking place in the same cocktail
of small molecules that were necessary for transcription.
So I decided that it would be useful to see which of those small molecules
was really required, not for the transcription part, but for the RNA splicing.
So I added them, I subtracted them one at a time from the transcription cocktail,
I added them back.  And I found that there were only two small molecules that were required:
one was a simple salt, magnesium chloride,
and the other was one of the precursors of RNA itself,
guanosine triphosphate.
A lot of specificity here: G was required, A wouldn't do it,
C wouldn't do it, U wouldn't do it. It had to be guanosine.
And this seemed unusual, it seemed interesting,
but we didn't really know what to make of it
until someone else in the laboratory, Art Zaug,
was sequencing the end of the intron
after it was excised from the larger RNA.
And he found that the sequence of the cut out RNA
started with a guanosine residue which is one of the four nucleotides of RNA.
We didn't think much of it until we found out from Joe Gall's laboratory
at Yale university, that they had sequenced the gene that encodes this RNA,
and that they were adamant that there was no guanine
present near that exon-intron boundary.
The rest of our sequences agreed between the two laboratories,
and so here we had a situation where it looked like maybe
there was a guanine that wasn't encoded by the DNA
that was added to the end of the intron.
And at the same time we had this evidence
from my earlier work that G was a required ingredient in the splicing reaction.
So maybe these two observation were related to each other,
although the idea that one could just add a guanosine triphosphate
to purified RNA and expect any chemical reaction,
any cutting and joining reaction, to take place seemed unprecedented
and really quite farfetched. So, at the time
I did this reaction rather, this experiment, rather quietly.
I didn't tell any of the graduate students what I was doing.
I didn't want to look foolish if this reaction
failed as it was probably destined to do.
When I added in one tube radiolabeled GTP to the purified precursor RNA
and in other tubes the other nucleotides
finally in the midst of my teaching schedule I had an opportunity to run the gel
to look at the splicing products, and lo and behold,
only in the lane where I had added the radiolabeled GTP
was there a radiolabeled RNA band the exact size of the intervening sequence.
So, I ran back to my office to try to get a little bit of peace and quiet
to try to draw out what must be happening in terms of the splicing mechanism.
and what I quickly came up with was that this guanine that was added during the splicing reaction
was being joined to the 5' end of the intron.
So it looked like it was attacking the splice site phosphate,
and forming a new oxygen-phosphorus bond that hadn't been there before.
Now if that happened, that would explain how the GTP would be covalently bound to
the end of the intron. But what would happen with the other product of this reaction?
Well, the 5' exon would then have to be released with a hydroxyl group at its 3' end.
And exactly the same kind of chemical step if it occurred now
between this exon and the downstream splice site
would result in ligation of the exons and release of the intron RNA
with this diagnostic guanosine at its 5' end.
And, so, I thought, well,  has anyone... is this even chemically reasonable?
So, fortunately I had an organic chemistry textbook within reach,
pulled it out. It did not discuss this sort of reaction
with phosphate esters, but with esters of carbon, this was simply a trans-esterification reaction.
So, what was happening...so there was precedent for this sort of reaction.
You start out with one ester linkage,
in this case a phospho-diester linkage, and you are now using
the hydroxyl group of the ribosugar of guanosine
as a nucleophile attack at this site.
It is also called an Sn2 reaction as you probably studied in your organic chemistry class.
And this swapping of partners in this ester linkage
turned out to be the key mechanism of RNA splicing.
So although it was exciting to have this mechanistic information
about RNA splicing, the question of the catalyst that was allowing all of this to happen eluded us
for another year. We were assuming that there had to be a protein enzyme
that was responsible for a reaction that took place with this incredible specificity,
after all in this long RNA there was only this one site that was being chosen as a splice site.
There was also specificity with respect to guanosine
relative to the other nucleotides. And the reaction was speeded up
many billions of fold faster than
a spontaneous phospho-transesterification reaction
would be predicted to occur.
So, if all biological catalysts are protein enzymes, where was the protein?
And we spent a lot of time looking for protein contaminants in our pure RNA preparation.
Finally, out of a lack of being able to identify any, we switched around the hypothesis
and said, maybe it is just the RNA that is folding up to form the catalytic center for this reaction.
To test that idea we were able to make an artificial transcript
that had never seen the inside of a Tetrahymena cell
and when we added guanosine triphosphate to that artificial RNA
the addition of G to the end of the intron
and the RNA splicing that ensued convinced us that it was time to announce
that RNA could be an enzyme, that RNA had catalytic activity.
This turned out to be the experiment, or the set of experiments,
that resulted in the Nobel Prize in Chemistry 8 years later,
but I think it is important to understand that at the time,
we were not driven by the possibility of getting awards
or recognition. It was simple curiosity about how does RNA splicing occur
and how could this reaction even be occurring with pure RNA
that was driving us in the laboratory
and giving us so much satisfaction.